your goal was to make the raunchiest
sort of most disgusting talk show in the
history dysfunctional talk show in
history I love the show opener always my
favorite part you're hanging from a hook
yeah and you seem to be half unconscious
yeah and then they just swing you from
the hook and your body just kind of
slams into [__] I mean that were you
injured doing that not that I was
injured the biggest injury I ever got
was interviewing Vivica Fox I like
jumped on top of my desk and landed my
tailbone right on the concrete and it
sent like a shock wave up my spine and I
was like walking around like the
hunchback of Notre Dame for the rest of
the year I thought it was like
asymmetrical for the rest of the year
did you go to the doctor did he tell you
what you had done I did uh no I just
went to a chiropractor and she kind of
just like gave me a massage you know we
should have gone to the doctor when we
watched these shows we think you guys
rehearse some of this stuff and that
like it's all figured out
you know do you worry for your life that
like some guy's going to come over and
just bust you in the head or something
yeah it's pretty scary the scariest bits
are on the subway and I just did the
Republican National Convention I did
both conventions but I did the arms who
had the better sense of humor was it the
RNC the NC was a little bit more mellow
they were a little more into like eating
pot brownies before their rallies the
RNC it was like open carry they all had
guns I went to a rally that was like a
bikers for Trump rally yeah and they all
had weapons and I did people threaten
you uh yeah what were you doing that
caused them to threaten you I walked
this um guy Alex Jones he's a little
hot-blooded you know so he was
um speaking at this uh bikers for Trump
rally and he was complaining about the
New World Order and the globalist you
know he's like a WWF wrestler he's like
I hate this and that and he's getting
the crowd all riled up and I walked up
and I had this giant fishing pole with a
microphone on it and I was trying to
interview him and then interview him
during his show
his speech right and then
um he was just like get The Daily Show
guy up here I guess he thought I was on
The Daily Show for some reason I don't
know who he thought I was right Jon
Stewart maybe
and then I walked on stage and he was
like what do you got to say for yourself
and I was like I want you to have sex
with my wife
he was like what and I was like no I'm
not joking here's my hotel Key I want
you to have sex with my wife and he's
like this guy's a distractor and blah
blah blah blah blah blah I was like
excuse me I only want to know uh why
does my pee pee come out yellow and he's
like get the [__] out of here
a lot of stuff yeah I mean you are
afraid for your life
terrifying party I'm split like part of
my mind knows that it's going to look
great in the edit and it's like the
higher the stakes the more nervous I am
the no the the better the bit is I'm
just know in the back of my mind do you
like doing the show still or love it or
do you feel like oh [__] it's so much
pressure to keep coming up it's
stressful shooting it's very stressful
making it and sometimes I fear for my
life and my health but um it's yeah it's
the most satisfying yeah in the world
good